Bagvat
[Música]
Budan
gami
[Música]
สัง
PBAN
[Música]
சна
B
Saran
Gan
[Música]
ตมัน
பிசனமி
[Música]
சம்ப
Agora nós vamos para as preces para
antes e depois dos ensinamentos.
através de homenagens, oferendas,
confissão, regozijo, solicitação e
súplica. Qualquer pequeno mérito que eu
tenha gerado, dedico a que todos possam
alcançar a iluminação.
A terra estão ungida de com água
perfumada,
espargida de flores e adornada pelo
sumero. quatro continentes, o sol e a
lua. Por eu ter imaginado e oferecido
isso como um reino búdico, possam todos
os seres usufruir dos reinos puros. A
terra estão ungida com água perfumada,
espargida de flores e adornada pelo os
quatro continentes, o sol e a lua. Por
eu ter imaginado e oferecido isso como
um reino búdico, possam todos os seres
usufruir dos reinos puros. A terra estão
ungida com água perfumada,
espargida de flores e adornada pelo
sumero, os quatro continentes, o sol e a
lua. Por eu ter imaginado e oferecido
isso como um reino búdico, possam todos
os seres usufruir dos reinos puros.
Miridan guru atma mandala
Mirame.
Para satisfazer as necessidades de todos
os seres em seus diversos níveis de
compreensão,
solicitamos a você que gire a roda do
dharma, incluindo as abordagens menores
e maiores, comuns e extraordinárias.
Através deste mérito, que todos os seres
possam se tornar oniscientes e alcançar
o estado búdico, derrotando todas as
faltas e impedimentos.
E todos os seres possam ser liberados do
existência condicionada,
agitada pelas ondas do nascimento, da
velice, da doença e da morte.
[Música]
Sex
guru
[Música]
do cantor
dan grup
[Música]
dan Gruppe de rom. Honr
grup
honra romar
grup.
[Música]
Honrazar
honra
grup.
[Música]
Hara
Grup
[Música]
Gruppe romar
Hraz
[Música]
de romar
Hraz
grup
honom
[Música]
Grup
honra
[Música]
Grup
honra romar
Hraz
grá
[Música]
honra
Grup
honra romar
grzar
[Música]
gurup de rom honom dan grup
hon rara
grup de rom hon rar
[Música]
para sangat
para
[Música]
mãe
de
parag
sangat
band
sate
[Música]
para
sangat
[Música]
paraгаang
sang
[Música]
Tempar
sang
gant
[Música]
Sanga
Ste
gaga
[Música]
sanga
de
[Música]
paragu
para
[Música]
Steгаo
Paraga
[Música]
para
S가
[Música]
de solar
para
de solте.
[Música]
Paragu
para sang
teu band.
[Música]
Então,
a gente tá seguindo
esse ensinamento, né, eu vou
vou comentar um pouco
as preces,
né?
E assim a gente quebra um pouco o
próprio ensinamento.
E então a gente olha um pouco esse tema.
Então é página 21 ou 22 aí de acordo com
for como for a sadana, né?
É 20 21, né?
Então a oferenda dos sete ramos, a gente
começa por isso, né?
Então, a gente vai olhar através de
homenagens,
prostrações oferendas confissão
regozijo, solicitação e súplica. Por
qualquer pequeno mérito que eu tenha
gerado, dedico a que todos possam
alcançar a iluminação.
Então, eu tô fazendo essa oferenda, né?
Então, a gente faz essa oferenda diante
dos Budas,
diante dos altares que representam os
Budas, né? Então nós fazemos homenagens.
Essas homenagens podem ser prostrações.
A gente faz oferendas também, como por
exemplo, oferenda de água pela manhã,
né? Oferas, oferenda de flores, oferenda
de limpeza. A gente faz as várias
oferendas, oferendas de visão elevada.
Aí nós fazemos confissão. A gente
confessa os problemas, as coisas que a
gente não conseguiu fazer direito.
A gente regozeja pelos bons resultados
de outros seres, de coisas boas que eles
tenham feito. Aí tem
súplica, né? Então essa descrição, ela
poderia ser assim, homenagens, né? Aí a
homenagem seria como que prostrações.
Então me prostro diante dos bodas que
que abençoaram os três templos, né?
Então aí tem muitas descrições dessas
dessas homenagens e prostrações.
Então a gente
faz homenagem aos budas, a gente
reconhece
ah o aspecto extraordinário disso, né?
que eles abençoaram os três tempos e
assim o mundo, na forma como ele se
apresenta, ele se torna um local que a
gente pode atingir a liberação, né? Eles
agraciaram os três templos.
Nós nos prostramos diante do dharma, dos
ensinamentos,
diante da sanga, suprema assembleia.
E a gente se dá conta que essas
manifestações do Buda, do Dharma e da
Sanga, elas representam corpos tão
numerosos quanto os átomos do universo.
Ou seja, não tem nenhum um pequeno
fragmento. Átomo nós vamos usar nesse
sentido, nenhum pequeno fragmento do
universo que a gente possa
conceber que não tenha não manifeste a
natureza búdica.
Todos os seres eles manifestam isso.
A gente pode não entender bem, mas aqui
é como os mestres estão ensinando. Então
essa visão eles têm como se fosse alguma
coisa completamente clara,
não é um aspecto religioso, alguma coisa
completamente clara,
mas vem as oferendas.
Então, assim como Mandiur e outros
fizeram oferendas aos budas,
né? Quais são as oferendas de mandura,
oferenda de sabedoria, né, que é a
oferenda mais elevada. Faço também
oferendas
aos que assim
progrediram. Então, a gente vai fazer
oferenda aos professores da sanga,
aqueles que nos ajudam a andar no
caminho e os budas essencialmente, né?
Aí nós confessamos,
né, essa confissão é assim, enfim, é o
reconhecimento da realidade. Desde que o
Sansara sem início se manifesta
nesta em outras vidas, a gente se dá
conta o que que eu tenho feito nessa em
outras vidas. Tô fazendo sempre a mesma
coisa.
É um fluxo mental que tá assim no meio
da confusão, soltando uma coisa para
outra.
Então essa confissão nem é confissão no
sentido, bá, eu sou horrível, não, mas
assim eu me dou conta do que que tem
acontecido, né? Então tem a confissão.
Então nós inadvertidamente
criamos coisas aflitivas para nós e pros
outros. E nós também indicamos e
educamos e ajudamos que outros façam a
mesma coisa que a gente faz. Enfim, dá
uma confusão, né?
E
e a gente confessa que a gente até
regozijou, a gente se alegrou em fazer
esse tipo de coisa como se fosse uma
grande coisa,
os nossos comportamentos cotidianos, né?
Então, vendo isso,
eu abertamente me dou conta e e declaro
e reconheço
aos bodas do fundo do coração que me o
que tem acontecido, é o que eu tenho
para oferecer. É isso. Foi o que o que
tem acontecido. Então isso é confissão.
Aí vem regozijo.
Com alegria eu me regozijo do oceano de
força positiva
do que brota de bodetita, né? Então
bodetita é como por exemplo a gente tava
explicando ontem, nós olhamos primeiro
nobre verdade que a gente vê como que a
gente se engana e aí como que então o
sofrimento surge, as dificuldades
surgem, mas isso pode se assar a se dar
conta. Aí quando a gente se dá conta
brota uma alegria assim, uma alegria por
nós e pelos outros. Então esse regozijo,
ele tá ligado a isso, né? Então, brota
uma alegria em nós que a gente vê que é
possível a gente agir de um outro modo
mais lúcido.
E aí nós vemos que a gente tem essa
bodetita, essa aspiração de ajudar os
outros seres e nós desejamos levar
felicidade a todos os seres
ah que estão operando desse modo como
nós estamos, né, e não estão vendo. E
assim nós vamos trabalhar, fazer esforço
pelo bem de todos.
Tem a súplica. Com as mãos pressionadas,
eu peço aos budas de todas as direções
que acendam a luz do dharma dentro das
nossas mentes e na mente de todos os
outros que estão assim simplesmente
vagueando, sem se dar conta de coisa
nenhuma. Que por favor essa lucidez
brote na mente deles, né?
Aí nós aspiramos também que os mestres
não passem para o nirvana final.
Então o nirvana final é mais ou menos
assim, por exemplo, que eles não
desapareçam.
Então eles morrem. Tudo bem. Aí pode
morrer, mestre, mas depois aparece de
novo aqui. É meio assim, né?
E então não é assim. Não vá por nirvana
final no sentido de retornar
a uma expressão livre que não mais se
manifesta dentro dos mundos
condicionados assim. Mas por favor, nós
estamos aqui,
né?
Então, aos budas,
eh,
eu aspirando passar além da dor, suplico
que, eh, eu e outros seres que vagueiam
os cegos sem ninguém para guiá-los,
não nos deixa assim vagueando sem rumo.
Por favor, vivam por eras incontáveis.
Aí vem a dedicação de méritos.
pela força positiva acumulada por tudo
que fiz dessa maneira aqui, fazendo
essas poucas oferendas, né? Que todos os
sofrimentos de todos os seres limitados
possam desaparecer.
Então isso é a primeira parte, né? Então
quando nós olhamos, por exemplo,
a sadana,
né, de chuva de bênçãos,
vocês vão encontrar
isso também, né?
Então essa dançãos,
eu acho que é página 24.
De uma olhada.
É isso, né?
Então, então nós vamos, a gente toma
refúgio no Marraguro. No Marraguro,
União de todas as fontes de refúgio,
toma o refúgio agora até a iluminação.
Maravilhoso, porque a gente toma refúgio
na fonte de todos os refúgios, que é o
topo do topo. Então, a gente pode vir
por vários caminhos, através mesmo por
várias tradições diferentes, mas é
evidente que nós vamos chegar todo mundo
no mesmo ponto.
Então nós estamos no Marraguro, união de
todas as fontes de refúgio, que seria o
refúgio verdadeiro, porque todos os
refúgios que não são esses são ainda
preliminares.
Eu me refugio em alguma coisa, depois eu
me dou conta que aquilo não é
suficiente, vou adiante, né?
Aí nós vamos indo como na nossa própria
vida humana, assim de ser fugir na mãe,
fugir no pai, na família, depois na
professora e vai se refugiando nos
amigos e nas várias coisas, nós vamos
indo, mas a gente não encontra uma fonte
de refúgio final, né? Mas existe uma
fonte de refúgio final.
Então é uma ranguro. Então para
estabelecer todos os seres que existem
por todo espaço no livro dos budas, eu
vou me empenhar neste caminho profundo
de guruga.
Então guru yoga é assim, é mergulhar em
direção à fonte de refúgio final. Esse é
o ponto. Mesmo que a gente não atinja
isso, nós estamos caminhando. A gente vê
um pouco, um pouco não vê, mas estamos
andando né?
Aí vem a descrição
de todo o dharma, todos os ensinamentos
do Buda, eles ficam descritos aqui.
Então digo a. Quando eu digo a, eu tô
falando da natureza luminosa da mente. A
que cria todo sansara. Então se eu
quiser perguntar o que que é o sansara,
eu digo: "Ah,
pessoas, ninguém entende nada. Não
entendeu?" Ah.
Por quê? Porque a natureza das
aparências é o aspecto luminoso. Nós
criamos, por exemplo, esse evento aqui
tá criado, nós estamos confortáveis aqui
dentro. Isso aqui é um barco normal, nós
estamos vendo tudo andando que nem o
Titanic, assim, todo mundo andando
normal, né? E aqui tem o Titanic, amanhã
o meio-dia,
bom,
termina o barco.
Assim são as coisas. Todas elas são
assim. Mas enquanto nós estamos andando,
tem aquilo que é chamado de normose, né?
Normose é não é propriamente a
ignorância, mas é a ignorância da
ignorância. Por exemplo, nós podemos
estar com a ignorância sabendo que nós
estamos na ignorância, mas a gente pode
estar na ignorância achando tudo normal.
Tudo normal. É nós tomar uma taça de
champanhe Convitanic
15 minutos antes.
E aí, pessoal? E aí, tudo bem? Nós tudo
magnífico.
Tá tudo maravilhoso, tá assim um mar
tranquilo,
tudo is é normose, vocês entendem? E aí,
como é que tão? Ah, tudo bem.
Super bem, assim, como dizia a pessoa
depois que se jogou no do 20º andar,
passando pelo quarto, n? E aí, como é
que tá? Não, tudo bem até aqui tudo bem,
né? É assim, então esse é o ponto. A
pessoa que se jogou do avião, o
paraquedista
não puxou ainda
o fiozinho, não descobriu que pulou sem
o paraquedas. Então é uma coisa e aí
como é que tá? Não, tudo normal. Tô
esperando aitude certa para
Então isso é que é chamado de normose.
P chamava assim.
Então no budismo isso é moa. Tem esse
nome moa que tem ignorância que a vídeo
que eu não vejo. Mas pessoal a gente não
vê que não vê. Aí sim
entende? É assim. Então nós estamos de
modo geral nisso, né? Nós somos anormos
porque a gente não vê que não vê
e não vê que não vê que não vê.
Aquilo só se soma assim, né? Agora nós
estamos vendo que a gente não vê. Isso
já é um super avanço, n? Isso é é a
ignorância original. A gente não vê, mas
a gente tá sabendo que nós estamos sendo
enganados. Não há dúvida.
Então,
a perante mim e minha forma ordinária
está o Iaculado Lago Dana Coxa de Ordem.
Então, começa com o a. Esse lago d na
coxa de ordem, ele tem água com as oito
qualidades, que é eh eh todas as
aparências vem de olhos ouvidos na le
língua, tato, mente. E aí as duas mentes
mais sutis, que é
que é a identidade, a bolha, sétima e
oitava consciência. Então aqui as as
oito qualidades são as oito consciências
que constróem realidades.
As nossas identidades, por exemplo, a
identidade nossa aqui no retiro tá
construída. Pessoal, eu acho que vocês
não estão com nenhuma pulseirinha, né?
Eh, faltou isso porque uma pulseira
sagrada assim.
Aí fica aí nós estamos identificados.
Sim, nós existimos como alguém dentro do
retiro, a identidade e provavelmente no
ali já diz retiro de tal coisa em tal
data, né? Eu acho que um retiro sério
tem que ter aquilo escrito, né? Aí
aquilo é a bolha. Aí nós não é que nós
tenhamos uma identidade, uma identidade
dentro daquilo.
Então são as oito consciências.
Então, a como é que surge as oito
consciências? Luminosidade da mente cria
todas as aparências.
É innegável.
Amanhã o nosso Titanic
bate no iceberg ao meio-dia.
Se não bater, o iceberg veio pela porta
e diz: "Olha, tem que terminar".
É um pouco assim, né?
Aí quando termina, pessoal, as nossas
identidades entram em colapso.
Nós surgimos em outros mundos. Que
mundos que a gente vai surgir? Os mundos
familiares. A gente corre para mostrar
com com a família, com os amigos, né? A
gente olha pro relógio para saber na
outra bolha como é que tá a nossa
situação, se nós estamos muito atrasados
ou não, né? E aí as coisas todas mudam.
A gente já telefona: "Vocês arrumaram
isso e fizeram aquilo? Já botaram tal
coisa no forno que eu já tô chegando.
Ninguém botou
e foram compraram tal coisa, não
compraram, não fizeram uma salada, não
fizeram. Então pronto, nós já estamos no
outro mundo.
Nossa consciência
e o budismo
é assim, a gente pensa, não, ainda vou
morar num lugar que eu só penso no Buda
e nada mais.
Não vai acontecer, pessoa
[Música]
coxa de ordem, suas profundezas
preenchidas por águas com as oito
qualidades. Em seu centro, uma ade flor
de lótus feita de joias.
Essa flor de lótus ela é lúcida. Todas
as aparências da flor de lótus, que é a
aspiração de trazer benefício aos seres,
é tudo lúcido. Quem é que tá sentado ali
em cima?
Ordeman, ou seja, grorpé ou Buda.
Aí tá consciência búdica sentada,
surgida desse modo para trazer benefício
aos seres.
Aí
reluzente no esplendor das marcas
maiores e menores. Isso significa o quê?
Que ele tem todas as qualidades dos
ensinamentos e toda a lucidez que os
budas podem ter.
Ele abraça de gual.
Essa parte é uma parte um pouco, vamos
dizer assim, um pouco escandalosa, né?
Se a gente for olhar assim como, mas o
Buda não era monge como é que coisa aí.
Agora o Buda tem uma namorada, né?
Mas aí a Isoial
e a Istoguial, pessoal, é essa que tá
aqui conversando no nosso ensinamento
aqui, é ela.
Mas eogial ela representa a o aspecto
externo que seria o mundo.
Então tem o praticante e tem o mundo.
Ela representa a sabedoria que vai
surgir. E todas as aparências são não
doais com a mente. Então eles não só
esse abraço é um abraço inseparável, um
abraço cósmico,
porque as aparências elas já surgem
abraçadas com a nossa mente. Então esse
é o ponto, né?
Aí nós colocamos assim que é uma forma
é uma forma como na Índia já se usava,
né?
Então surge essa imagem.
Essa imagem, ela também evoca os casais.
Quando as pessoas se olham, elas
constróem alguma coisa, mas alguma coisa
é inseparável de uns e outros. Não é que
seja uma realidade, mas é uma uma não
dualidade que surge,
né? É assim, ele segura um vagera na mão
direita. E o que que ele tá fazendo com
a mente? Ele usa um vagra. Vajra é esse
objeto aqui.
Ele segura um vajra na mão direita. O
vajera significa a visão vagera, a visão
da vacuidade e luminosidade.
Então ele tá olhando tudo com um olho
que vê a vacuidade, luminosidade, não
dualidade.
Ele não tá olhando com olho comum.
Aí tem um vaso dentro de uma taça de
crânio. A taça de crânio ela significa a
mente. O vaso é a grande vacuidade.
Então a taça de crânio, a mente ela ela
tá dentro dessa grande espacialidade.
Eu tenho taça de crânio e eu tenho o
vaso. E a taça de crânio, ela representa
o universo todo, porque o universo é
inseparável da minha mente.
Requintados em sua sedas e ornamentos de
joias de osso. Então eles estão com eles
estão requintados de suas sedas. Eh,
esse aspecto das sedas e das joias de
osso significa a realização da vacuidade
dos aspectos internos do corpo
dentro de uma vasta expansão de luz de
cinco cores. Então, deles emanam as
luzes das cinco sabedorias. Então, eles
têm a sabedoria do espelho, sabedoria da
igualdade, sabedoria discriminativa,
sabedoria da causalidade, sabedoria de
dar mata. Então eles, é como nós aqui,
por exemplo, a gente pode pensar, bom,
eu tô eu vou fazer essa prática. Eu tô
aqui fazendo essa prática por quê?
Porque tô olhando o mundo como não doal.
Eu tô dentro da taça de crânio,
que é a bolha que eu tô aqui, é a minha
mente. Eu tô dentro dessa bolha. Me
sinto existindo aqui dentro dessa bolha,
né? Eu tô aqui.
As aparências são totalmente não duais
comigo.
Eu tô abraçado nas aparências. As
aparênças, eu não consigo separar as
aparências. Eu tô vendo as aparências.
Elas são, elas estão dentro de olhos,
ouvidos, nariz, língua e tato.
Mas elas não são reais. Tanto que vai
terminar amanhã o meio-dia.
Mas eu tô magnetizado por isso.
E reconhecendo isso, eu manifesto a
sabedoria do espelho. Eu vou olhando
seres com sabedoria do espelho. Eu vejo
que eles estão em mundos semelhantes,
eles estão nos seus próprios mundos.
Então, sabedoria do espelho, sabedoria
da igualdade, ou seja, todos eles estão
em diferentes mundos, mas é a mesma
coisa. Eles estão presos do mesmo jeito.
Sabedoria da igualdade, sabedoria
discriminativa. Eu vejo como é que
aquilo surge, como aquilo existe por um
tempo, depois cessa. E é isso. Eu tô
vendo.
Eu vejo como a gente faz uma ação de um
tipo, produz um resultado. A gente faz
ações de outro tipo, produz outros
resultados, mesmo dentro do mundo
condicionado.
É assim, é incrível.
Vocês olham o poder de um sin assim,
plim, todo mundo levanta
ou plim, todo mundo fica em silêncio. É
isso. Causalidade direta assim.
Mas o que que é a quinta cor? O branco.
O branco representa dar, que é o fato de
que tudo isso se dá a partir de uma
natureza livre que constrói de um jeito,
constrói de outro jeito, etc. Então eu
vejo armata aqui a quinta cor. Então vej
a cor azul, sabedoria do espelho, cor
amarela, sabedoria da igualdade, cor
vermelha, sabedoria discriminativa, cor
verde, sabedoria da causalidade e cor
branca sabedoria de dar mata, que é a
grande expansão que nós temos o tempo
todo falando aqui.
E aí eles resplandecem
na majestade
e na bênção da suprema felicidade
sublime. Por quê? Porque quando nós
olhamos isso, tem uma alegria interna.
Quando nós começamos a ver as aparências
como elas verdadeiramente são.
Então isso é a suprema felicidade
sublime.
Legiões das três raízes
congregam-se como nuvens, formando seu
secto. As três raízes são Lama, Iban e
Daquini. Então, todos os mestres,
todas as deidades, como Aratara, como
Tierenzigo, como Andurer, como
Vajaquilaia, como Conim, todas as
deidades que a gente possa olhar de
qualquer direção, todas elas emanam a
partir desse centro lúcido.
Elas são aparências desse centro lúcido.
Todos os lamas são isso também. Então,
lamas, idans e daquines, eles formam o
secto. Eles são eles são expressões
operativas
desse aspecto lúcido.
Então, não há nenhum ida, nenhuma
deidade que esteja falando qualquer
coisa que não isso. Todas elas convergem
para esse ponto. Todos os lamas fazem o
quê? Eles vão explicar isso de um jeito
ou de outro. É isso que eles estão
fazendo. Todas as daquinhas, elas vão se
aproximar
dos lugares onde os seres estão presos
pela ignorância e por moa, onde eles
estão presos pela ignorância ou pela
ignorância da ignorância, elas se
aproximam e explodem aquilo.
Esse é o papel das
elas vão produzir quando os universos se
arrumam.
Nós temos sempre uma porta que conecta
com outros universos.
Desses outros universos vem os seres que
vão tensionar o nosso universo assim
diretamente. É como se a gente tivesse
aqui no meio disso e alguém aqui dentro
tem um chili que cai no chão. Aí todo
mundo para, para tudo, vai socorrer.
Ou alguém entra pela porta com uma arma.
Pronto, quebrou o nosso Titanic antes do
tempo.
Vocês entendem? Então, as daquinas têm o
poder de quebrar a bolha.
Aquele
aquele iceberg lá, a gente podia chamar
iceberg daquini.
Tava todo mundo super bem, super direito
aquilo. Aí daqui falou lá, explodiu
tudo.
Não, esse é o ponto. Asquinas explodem a
normose.
Vocês podem imaginar que tem pessoas que
têm esse essa vertigem.
Eu acho que o Buda é um desses, né?
Porque ele vai chegar nos lugares, vai
falar sobre as quatro noves verdades,
vai explodir o sentido comum das coisas,
né? Esse é o papel dele. Mas as seres,
as daquines são representados como seres
femininos voando no céu. Então esse
aspecto de voar no céu significa que
elas não têm uma base terra.
Elas elas não têm um referencial comum.
Por exemplo, elas entram aqui, elas não
dão uma olhada o que que elas estão
fazendo. Vou sentar no canto quietinho
até eu entender. Tá todo mundo meio
estranho com umas cara meio estranha.
Tem uns pelo chão aqui, mas deve ser
tudo normal assim, né? Então elas não
entram com essa cara,
elas não estão procurando a terra para
ver. elas chegam e elas elas têm a
clareza
eh da normose, então elas vão explodir
aquilo.
Assim, eu acho que na nossa cultura as
daquinas não são muito bem-vindas assim,
porque na medida que a gente tem apegos
à várias estruturas, a gente não quer
nada com quem vem para destruir tudo,
para destruir as coisas. Nós estamos
protegendo que as coisas não se
destruam, né? Não é assim. Então, as
daquinas não são bem vistas, mas nas
culturas dos povos da terra, eu não vou
dizer todas, né? Não gosto de
generalizar isso, mas eu já vi vários
relatos
no sentido de que os seres que
descompensam, que a gente diria, eles
descompensaram, eles, na verdade, eles
são vistos como manifestações divinas,
né?
Então, as pessoas elas respeitam, elas
olham, elas tentam entender, elas querem
ver que o que que tá acontecendo, que
mensagem é aquela, porque é são formas
especiais de quebrar as delusões, né?
Então a
as daquines têm esse poder, que é um
processo completamente diferente
dos processos
eh do estudo, análise, sustentação de
visões equilíbrio completamente
diferente. Mas tem essa bênção da
destruição, né? um aspecto
assim
e olhando aquele cabelo dele assim me
pareceu assim mesmo, né?
Então o Trump ele tá nessa condição
assim né?
Vai sobrar nada. Mas os demônios também
tão sabe se é demônio.
É melhor olhar todos os demônios como
daquines, porque aí tu, uau, olha aí. Aí
tu aproveita e vai entendendo aquilo
tudo como é que é, né? Eu acho isso
super favorável assim.
Então eles me fitam fazendo cair uma
chuva de bção e compaixão. Aí vocês
estão meditando aí, de repente estão os
budas tudo olhando para vocês nas ops,
ops, eles me fitam,
fazendo cair uma chuva de bênçãos e de
compaixão. Ou seja, tem uma
visão. Nós vemos, eles nos vem.
E aí vem a oferenda. Eu vejo eles, aí
vou fazer as oferendas. Então começa
assim. Primeira a forma da imortal
sabedoria primordial que é a verdadeira
face de todos os vitoriosos. Ofereço, tô
oferecendo oferendas. Eu ofereço o quê?
E por todo sempre prostrações de fé com
intenso e poderoso anseio. Ponto um,
oferendas.
E aí, meu corpo, minha riqueza, meus
prazeres e todas as virtudes escolhidas
nos três tempos ofereço sobre a forma
das vastas nuvens de oferendas de
Samanta Padra. Não é prostrações,
oferendas, aí vem, confesso,
sem exceção,
todas as ações nocivas e faltas
acumuladas ao longo do tempo sem
princípio, das qualidades dos vitoriosos
seus herdeiros. você é o único senhor
soberano.
Aí eu tenho essa essa confissão.
Confesso todas as ações nocivas e faltas
acumuladas ao longo do tempo sem
princípio. Pá,
se nós estamos meditando nessa sadana, é
bom que a gente pare um pouquinho e a
gente faça isso mesmo, a gente se dê
conta disso.
Aí vem
regozijo, senhor protetor em seu
exemplo,
regozijo-me de coração. Então regozijo
porque os budas existem, a lucidez
existe. Eu me alegro por isso, pá.
Aí eu vou pedir
a você rezou com fé. Súplica, né?
suplicando-lhe
que faça cair sobre nós uma imensa chuva
do dharma vasto e profundo.
É isso que eu quero que caia o dharma,
que eu possa entender, eu possa
ultrapassar delusão.
Aí vem o sexto aspecto.
É como a gente a gente tá pedindo que os
mestres não passem para nirvana final. o
sexto aspecto, mas aqui não tá com essas
palavras aqui tá assim: "Reumindo todas
as qualidades virtuosas
minhas e dos outros
irei." Então nós não pedimos que eles
não passem, mas nós pedimos para nós
mesmos representarmos aquilo. Então,
reunindo todas as qualidades virtuosas
minhas e dos outros, irei enquanto
perdurar os incontáveis reinos de seres.
seguir o seu exemplo. Então, nós estamos
ocupando o lugar do outro, nós vamos
fazer aquilo acontecer. Então, nós
estamos pedindo a bênção para que a
gente possa seguir e manifestar
o exemplo dos budas.
Aí vem a dedicação.
Dedico tudo que os seres de todo espaço
possam ser guiados.
grande tesouro de sabedoria e amor, em
quem convergem todas as fontes de
refúgio.
Então aí segue aí as preces elas mudam
um pouco. E isso é a Sadana. Essa então
a base da Sadana é as as oferendas, né?
Assim. Eu não vou estender porque esse
não é o nosso tema, mas vocês vão
perceber dentro da sadana, se vocês
tiverem um olho que fica atento, vocês
vão perceber em outros lugares também
eles vão usar essa estrutura.
né? Então, as grandes chuvas de bênçãos
vocês vão elas
em outras partes da daqui vocês vão
encontrar também essas estruturas de
dessa visão assim, né?
Mas as palavras mudam de acordo com a
realização
dos mestres que estão falando, né?
Então, a gente olhou isso, nós já
completamos essa parte. Agora a gente
volta ao nosso texto. Nós vamos entrar
agora no item quatro do texto, que é a
página 24.
Aí Leidsuial perguntou: "Ô mestre,
qual ponto essencial contém todos os
tipos de sabedoria?"
Então ele tá descrevendo
de um modo com diferentes palavras o
mesmo ponto último.
É sempre assim, né? Então agora ele vai
chamar esse ponto essencial, que é o
ponto último. Ele vai dar, ele vai
reconhecer que tem outras qualidades
operando ali dentro. Então ele vai
dizer, mestre respondeu, o estado
desperto autoexistente. Então antes era
grande abertura, era o espaço, né? Agora
ele tá dizendo o estado desperto
autoexistente.
Então o estado desperto autoexistente
ele é inseparável do do da experiência
de espaço. Porque quando eu olho pro
espaço, eu não vejo objetos,
mas nós estamos ali olhando. Então o que
que é isso? que não é uma identidade,
não é a discriminação de coisas, mas é
simplesmente um olho atento e vivo. Esse
é o estado desperto autoexistente.
Essa é uma das formas de viver a grande
vacuidade. Grande vacuidade é o estado
de esperto autoexistente.
Sim.
Eh,
por exemplo, dependendo das tradições,
eles vão privilegiar a descrição de um
jeito ou de outro. No zem, nós vamos
descrever mais próximamente do estado de
esperto autoexistente,
que ele também pode ser descrito como
tatata, né? Ou seja, no silêncio nós
estamos vivos.
Não há como interromper essa essa
condição de lucidez,
nem no silêncio. No silêncio e na
ausência de qualquer objeto, qualquer
atividade mental,
essa vida ela tá presente.
Então, esse é um ponto,
um ponto muito importante, porque ele
vai nos ajudar a reconhecer que nós
temos além de vida e morte.
Essa é a conexão que nos leva a
reconhecer isso, né? Como que a gente
percebe esse estado
autoexistente?
estado de esperto autoexistente, a gente
descobre ele pela ação dele.
Vocês já vejam, por exemplo, nós estamos
aqui dentro do nosso Titanic que vai
terminar amanhã o meio-dia.
A nossa ação mental, ela tá ligada aqui
às palavras, as coisas que estão
acontecendo, que a gente vê acontecendo
aqui dentro, né?
E esse é o é o que nós vemos como ação
da mente. Então, ação da mente é tudo
que acontece dentro do navio que tá se
deslocando.
Então, nós temos um barco aqui que é o
evento. Aqui dentro a gente conversa
normal aqui,
mas a gente não se dá conta que tem uma
natureza luminosa
sustentando a criação desse desse
evento. A gente não se dá conta, mas se
a gente dá conta que o evento é
artificial e que ele tem hora para
terminar, a gente pergunta: "Mas essa
aparente naturalidade,
parece que a coisa dura para sempre?
Essa aparente naturalidade, ela vem do
quê? Ela vem dessa construção.
Essa construção, eu não me vejo
construindo. Isso é ação luminosa da
mente. Ação luminosa da mente é
inseparável
desse estado desperto autoexistente.
Então, por exemplo, nós saímos daqui
para outra coisa. O estado de esperto
autoexistente eh constrói outra coisa e
outra coisa e outra coisa e outra coisa.
Ele se tiver apenas o espaço vazio,
o grande espaço, ele tá lá vivo dentro
daquela dentro daquela experiência.
Quando vocês começam a desenvolver uma
familiaridade com os estados internos da
mente, a gente se dá conta que a nossa
visão, ela não precisa de olhos ouvidos,
nariz lingua e tato, porque todos esses
fenômenos que a gente tá descrevendo
aqui, eles não são vistos por olhos
ouvidos, nariz linguitato. Nada disso
aqui é visto por olhos ouvidos,
narizato. Nós estamos vendo porque nós
olhamos para dentro.
Im. Então, por exemplo, a gente não vai
ver uma bolha
como tal se a gente não olhar para
dentro da nossa mente, ver como é que
ela tá operando. A gente não vai ver o
aspecto delusivo da bolha, da
identidade, etc. Se a gente não tiver
olhando para dentro, a gente não vai
encontrar isso pelos olhos, pelos
ouvidos.
É como, por exemplo,
se a gente pensar que são os olhos que
vêm quando a gente lê, a gente vai se
atrapalhar pessoal porque
a gente traz um um livro de outra
língua, a gente não consegue ler.
Então, não é os risquinhos,
tem uma estrutura interna. E como é que
eu vejo que é uma estrutura interna e
não são risquinhos? porque eu tô olhando
para dentro da minha mente.
Então esse processo interno, ele é o
processo, a nossa vida, ela decorre como
fenômeno interno sempre.
O fenômeno externo, ele é um fenômeno
interno,
mas de modo geral a gente não se dá
conta disso.
Mas é aquilo é muito óbvio.
Então existe um estado desperto,
autoexistente nesse mundo interno. Esse
mundo interno não apaga nem quando a
pessoa morre. Pessoal, vocês querem se
livrar desse mundo interno? Não adianta.
É assim, vocês estão condenados a
viver no samsara enquanto sansara durar.
Então quando a gente morre, o sansara
não fecha, não não não interrompe,
porque esse processo ele segue.
Então o mestre respondeu,
né, qual é o ponto essencial que contém
todos os tipos de sabedoria? Ele diz: "O
estado de esperto autoexistente é o
ponto essencial de todos os tipos de
sabedoria.
Então isso é sambogakia. De lá surge
surgem
todas as sabedorias.
Já as sabedorias que dependem de
construções mentais e estão ligadas a
fenômenos comuns, elas mudam. não
perdura
e nem a ciência, né? Então ela depende
de configurações.
Ela aquelas verdades, elas duram por um
tempo e depois elas cessam.
Já o estado auto estado desperto
autoexistente,
naturalmente presente desde o início
primordial,
é a natureza de dar
um autoconhecimento ilimitado,
que é justamente essa capacidade de
olhar para dentro e ver isso a gente
poderia chamar também de rig. Ausência
dessa capacidade, ausência dessa
operação eh descrita como marigma, ou
seja, ignorância. Aí nós olhamos tudo
como se fosse externo, olhamos tudo como
a gente gosta ou não gosta. a gente não
vê mais os fenômenos como eles realmente
são. É nós ficamos operando nesse no
mundo externo.
Para esse estado de esperto,
autoexistente,
nada permanece desconhecido.
Porque a mente vendo como é que ela tá
operando, aí a mente não consegue se
esconder da mente, a mente vê como é que
a mente funciona. Então, nada permanece
desconhecido, nada permanece oculto,
nada permanece incompreendido,
visto que esse estado desperto,
autoexistente é desperto
e insondável em em essência.
Aí, por exemplo, por que que ele é
insondável? Porque assim, eu tô olhando
como que a minha mente está e como que
ela tá operando carmicamente, como que a
ignorância acontece, como que eu fico
preso, como que eu fico iludido pelo
próprio evento aqui, como é que as
coisas vão terminar amanhã, como é que
eu ve, como é que eu vejo isso tudo? Eu
pergunto: "Para aí,
como é que eu tô vendo isso?"
né? Então é uma pergunta,
uma pergunta
é uma meta pergunta, né? Porque eu não
tô nem olhando os conteúdos, eu tô
olhando como que eu vejo os conteúdos.
Aí se a pessoa
olha isso, ela se dá conta que
esse estado de desperto e lúcido, ele é
insondável. Eu não consigo localizá-lo.
Não vejo nenhum lugar físico, nenhum
tempo também. Ele não é dependente de
tempo, nem de espaço, mas ele ele brota,
né?
Na verdade, a estrutura disso, ela tá
ligada ao seguinte aspecto.
Por exemplo, a nossa mente, ela pode
criar artificialidades.
De novo, assim, eu vou sair do evento
aqui porque eu já cansei desse exemplo.
Vamos para um exemplo original que vocês
nunca ouviram, o jogo de xadrãz, né?
Mas você me descobriu, eu tinha que
encontrar um banco de exemplos assim,
mas eu fico do do mesmo exemplo do
assim, é uma situação, né? Mas aí eu tô
lá com o jogo com, né?
Aí
nós, a gente diz torre, peão, cavalo,
etc. né?
Então eu tô criando um sentido para
aquilo
que tá além da peça.
O estado desperto reconhece isso.
Aí eu pergunto: Estado desperto, estado
desperto. Revele sua verdadeira face
agora. Ordeno, né? Está desperto.
Me encontre se você conseguir.
Aí nós, onde é que ele tá? Porque ele
fala. Ele é uma voz que fala. Eu não sei
de onde é que essa voz tá falando.
Ela sempre fala alguma coisa direita,
sabe tudo. É pior que a minha mãe.
Adivinha o que eu tô pensando, né? Então
vocês vão se dar conta que é o seguinte.
Estado desperto. Estado desperto. Peguei
você.
Assim, a gente cria as coisas, por
exemplo, a gente cria a torre como tal.
Quando a gente cria,
a gente vê o que criou, não é verdade?
Porque senão a gente não pode dizer que
criou. Então, cria aí. Eu tô vendo a
torre. Olha a torre, né?
Quando eu vejo a torre,
esse fato de que eu tô vendo a torre, eu
não consigo ocultar da própria mente,
porque a mente tá vendo.
Então, quando a mente opera e vê a
torre, a própria mente que vê a torre vê
que ela tá vendo a torre.
Então eu não consigo, por exemplo, fazer
uma operação da mente que a própria
mente não veja o que que a mente tá
fazendo entende?
E disso vem o estado de esperto
autoconhecedor.
Aí tem esse modo de ação que é o estado
desperto autoconhecedor.
Eu posso criar, por exemplo, um artista,
tch tchã, ele cria.
Mas pode ser que ele simplesmente crie
as coisas,
mas ele tem o poder de dizer: "A minha
mente criou. Eu vejo minha mente
criando.
Ele tem o poder. Mas como é que você
criou isso?
Aquilo apareceu assim. Pum, eu criei.
É assim. Esse esse ponto dos artistas é
interessante, sabe? Porque alguns se é
ou não é eu não sei, mas a história é
bem contada, né? Então eu vi, por
exemplo, o Leonardo da Vin tem esse
registro dele, eu vi um flash uma vez
que o Leonardo da Vin ele sentava diante
de uma parede e ele era praticante zen
sem saber,
né? Só falta a gente dizer o Leonardo
Daviente fundou o Zé, entendeu? Então
assim, essas coisas acontecem.
Aí tá o Leonardo V lá olhando pra
parede.
E vocês já notaram que quando a gente
olha para uma parede começa a aparecer
todo tipo de coisa?
Pois é. Aí ele ia estabilizando aquilo
até que aquilo aparecia claro para ele.
Aí ele tchá tchá. Ele desenhava.
Assim ficou fácil, né? Por quê? Porque
ele ele desenha buscando
na no estado de esperto atemporal e
aquilo quando vem já vem com energia,
né? Lá tá.
Aí quando ele tá pintando já apareceu na
mente. Ele só tá botando cor naquilo que
ele tá vendo.
Isso é uma dica, pessoal. Isso é melhor
que inteligência artificial.
Por quê? Porque essa mente ela é ela
produz mundos, né? A inteligência
artificial landa por dentro dos mundos
que já foram produzidos. Aquilo é tudo
fake, é tudo, né?
Então esse estado de esperto
autoexistente
faz parte do nosso processo. Nós estamos
contemplando também o estado de esperto
autoexistente.
Aí pense quem tá meditando, pessoal não
tá perdendo tempo.
Se der tudo errado, vira um grande
pintor.
Então qual o ponto essencial contém
todos os tipos de sabedoria?
Estado desperto autoexistente, o
autoconhecimento limitado. Para esse
estado desperto autoexistente, nada
permanece desconhecido.
E olha para dentro e vê como que aquilo
tá operando. Nada permanece
incompreendido.
Visto que esse estado desperto,
autoexistente, é desperto,
insondável em sua essência, ele é também
a base para todos os dharmas e
sabedorias.
Os dharmas e sabedorias, eles são apenas
o descortinar daquilo que tá sendo, que
tá acontecendo.
Nós não estamos inventando nada, a gente
só tá vendo como é que aquilo tá
acontecendo.
É assim,
ele também é o seu local de permanência,
o local onde você tá. E é, portanto,
conhecido como ponto essencial que
contém todos os tipos de sabedoria.
Mess Dog, ele ele escreveu esse tratado,
né, que é o olho da verdadeira lei. tá
despertando atemporal, o olho que vê
todo o dharma,
porque uma coisa é ver o dharma e outra
coisa ver como que eu tô vendo o dharma,
como é que a lucidez aparece dentro de
mim, qual a origem dela.
Aí Leuial nem se impressionou, deixou
aqui assim, ela perguntou ao mestre qual
o tipo essencial,
qual ponto essencial contém todos os
tipos de samad. Então samad são
meditações. De modo geral, por exemplo,
dentro dos yogas súras de Patangel,
Samad é como se fosse o ponto final.
Mas no budismo não é.
No budismo, o ponto final é o ponto
essencial que contém todos os tipos de
samate,
ou seja, a natureza livre da mente de
onde brotam os estatus particulares de
mente. O Buda tem esse ponto, os estatus
particulares de mente eles surgem e
cessam. Então eles não são ponto final.
Ponto final é o lugar de onde os estados
mentais surgem. Porque esse lugar onde
os estados mentais surgem, ele tá sempre
disponível. essa grande abertura. Então,
de lá surge os estados mentais.
O mestre respondeu: "Um samade da
talidade é o ponto essencial de todos os
samades."
Então, a talidade é essa condição
natural não construída.
Atalidade. Então o Samad, nós tomarmos
isso por refúgio, é descrito como samade
da talidade. É o ponto essencial de
todos os samades.
Os outros samadas mudam e não perduram.
Samades construídos. Samad samad da
talidade é da armata.
É a sua verdadeira identidade.
Soguial.
Entenda isso.
Sam da natalidade é dar o grande espaço.
Se de repousar na experiência do grande
espaço. Esse é o samade da talidade.
É a natureza original. Livre de erros.
Por quê? Livre de erros por porque não
tem nada. Não construo nada. Livre de
erros tal como ela é. É identidade
verdadeira, não elaborada.
de onde brotam as realidades, onde a
gente cria as realidades elaboradas.
Simplesmente sendo essa natureza,
a vacuidade do samade da talidade inclui
todos os outros tipos de samade, sem
exceção,
pois eles estão contidos
nesse mesmo estado, ou seja, de desse
estado brotam todos.
A gente pode dizer que o nosso evento
aqui é um tipo de samade,
que nós geramos um estado de mente que a
gente sustenta.
Nós estamos sustentando sem esforço.
Ele brota de uma grande abertura e ele
cessa. Então esses samares ele surge e
cessa.
Simplesmente sendo essa natureza, a
vacuidade do samadi, da talidade, inclui
todos os outros tipos de Samad, sem
exceção, pois eles estão contidos neste
mesmo estado.
Cada possível tipo de dharma e cada
aspecto do estado de esperto,
incontáveis como eles forem, estão
contidos sem exceção no estado livre de
esforço da vacuidade original, tal como
ela é.
Então, voltando assim, aí nós temos o
retiro, a gente construiu isso, só que a
gente não vê que a gente construiu, está
operando, mas a gente sai desse estado
para outro. A gente amanhã ao meio-dia
nós zupte para casa e parece que aquilo
não é construído, mas aquilo também é
construído. Aí nós chegamos em casa,
aquilo é construído. Dali nós vamos
fazer, não sei bem o que no final da
tarde. Aí tum é outra coisa construída.
Aí nós vamos para ambientes construídos.
Quando a gente tá calmo naquele ambiente
construído, visitando um amigo sentado
ali coisa, conversando,
nós temos uma construção luminosa, nós
temos um Titanic que vai andar
plim 10:30 da noite, nós, uau, tenho que
ir para casa. Amanhã é cedo, tem que
estar em pé, tem que fazer outras
coisas, aquilo plim.
Mas nós temos um conforto, uma calma
durante um tempo. Isso são estados
construídos.
Então eles eles brotam dessa grande
liberdade de construir
estados particulares.
Então todo estado particular construído,
ele é uma expressão da liberdade
da talidade original que por sua vez não
é construída. Mas eu sei que essa
talidade original, ela tá lá, porque eu
vejo que eu surjo de um jeito, depois eu
surjo de outro jeito, surge de outro
jeito e quando aquilo cessa, eu volto
para um estado
natural
a partir do qual eu vou construir outra
coisa.
Então, nós somos a a nossa essência é
esse estado que é não construído,
que também não precisa ser sustentado
porque ele tá lá.
Então, essa noção que a gente tem que
fazer esforço e sustentar e fazer muitos
esforços, etc., Ela vem da nossa
experiência comum,
que a gente tá numa condição de uma
bolha. Dentro da bolha, eu quero o que
eu gosto, eu quero me afastar do que eu
não gosto. Então eu sujo os elementos,
surge o elemento terra e aí começa, aí
surge o elemento água, aí surge o
elemento fogo que eu tenho que fazer
esforços. Aí eu passo a vida fazendo
esforços.
Por quê? Porque eu quero que as coisas
sejam de um jeito e não de outro. E as
coisas tem uma deslizar em várias
direções,
já conversando com o pessoal da casa
mesmo que vai fazendo uma bagunça
enquanto a gente vai arrumando.
[Música]
Aí a gente transmite para eles, né? Te
dá a transmissão
do sofrimento, do tipo, um dia você vai
ter a sua casa, você vai ter seus
filhos. Aí eu quero ver o que que vai
fazer fazer.
Aliás, a gente já ouviu antes, não é
verdade?
Aquilo é bonito de ver, né? A gente vai
passando, dando a transmissão. Agora
quero ver você.
Mas quando os filhos estão passando mal,
o que que eles fazem? Mamãe, vem aqui.
Aí a mamãe sempre,
ela vai lá, surge como salvadora, né? É
maravilhoso isso.
Mas então nós podemos surgir de qualquer
modo, né? E nós podemos surgir de
qualquer modo para
salvar, para ajudar, para fazer as
coisas acontecerem. Nós nos criamos
nesse desses mundos,
mas nós criamos a partir do quê? De uma
natural liberdade, né?
Se a gente tiver fixado no nosso próprio
mundo, a gente não consegue socorrer o
outro direito,
porque nós estamos fixados no nosso
mundo. Nós vamos fazer o quê? te diz:
"Olha, eu até iria ir, mas agora
imagina, tô fazendo, tô no meio disso.
Pode ser semana que vem, semana que vem
o outro já morreu.
[Risadas]
É isso.
Não é que a gente não possa, a gente até
pode, mas a nossa identidade, ela tá
operando dentro de uma bolha com uma
série de funções, né, meu filho, você
não podia me chamar no outro horário?
Não tá vendo que eu agora aqui eu não
posso.
É um pouco assim, né? Aí nós estamos
mais estreitos.
Mas mesmo essa identidade mais estreita,
ela veio de uma de um lugar amplo, né?
Assim.
Então, no budismo, essas partes aqui
também elas conectam. A gente pode puxar
uma setinha pro lado e descrever terra
pura, por exemplo. Então, as terras
puras elas não são o sansar usual, é um
lugar onde a gente consegue, por
exemplo estudar meditar viver né?
Então aqui esse evento é um fragmento de
terra pura, assim, por quê? Porque que
estranho, nós todos estamos reunidos
aqui e parece que
se a gente não tivesse esse evento, a
gente não tava aqui estudando esse tipo
de coisa. Então as terras puras existem,
elas surjam fundo e começa a acontecer.
Aí vem o Buda descrevendo: "As terras
puras são como barcos
e as pessoas dentro das terras puras,
elas vão elas vão fazendo uma
transformação até que elas vão atingir
liberação em algum momento.
As terras puras são muito importantes.
Do mesmo jeito que a gente constrói o
sansara, nós podemos construir terras
puras. Dus jeito que a gente constrói
guerras, pessoal, muito melhor uma
festa, né? Muito melhor. Então, em
comparação, não sei como que as pessoas
enlouquecem.
Então, portanto, isso é conhecido como a
reunião de todos os sames em um único
ponto essencial. A gente poderia olhar
aqui os sames como estados particulares
de mente que são estabilizados. Então,
poderia dizer, isso aqui é a reunião de
todas as bolhas
em um único ponto essencial.
As bolhas a gente não precisa olhar como
se fosse um grande problema. Criar uma
bolha não é fácil.
Criar mente que sustenta uma bolha não é
fácil.
Então, por exemplo, as mães tentam
tentam
eh transmitir a bolha da casa, da
família, né? Mas parece que dentro da
casa só tem uma pessoa que tenta aqui.
Só tem uma pessoa que sabe quando a
lâmpada queimou, que a roupa tem que
recolher, que tem que ir no
supermercado, todo mundo come daquela
geladeira, mas ninguém pensa o que tem
que comprar e nem anota em nenhum lugar
o que tem que comprar. Aí a mãe tem que
olhar aquilo, tem que adivinhar o que
que as belezas vão comer, o que que elas
vão querer e no fim da tarde qual vai
ser o lanche, porque eles mesmos não vem
isso.
Eu não tô reclamando, isso é só um
desabafo assim.
É isso aí. Tem alguém que é o regente
daquela mandala, vocês entendem?
Não queiram isso.
Não, mas é assim. Aí os regentes estavam
andavam tão felizes lá, as crianças tudo
correndo, a maior bagunça, mas é muito
bom isso.
E então,
mas tem um único ponto essencial de
todos esses estados mentais.
Esse ponto essencial é assim, ainda que
as casas sejam diferentes, os lugares
sejam diferentes, né, tem uma natureza
livre que vai construindo isso. Ainda
que os tempos vão mudando, tem sempre
uma natureza livre que constrói as
múltiplas aparências e irreferenciais e
bolhas que se manifestam, sendo que
essas bolhas elas são um estado mental
que passa a operar sem que tu veja.
Aquilo é semelhante a um samad. Só que o
samade é como se eu precisasse primeiro
sentar para depois botar a mente no
lugar.
No vajaiana, com sinais, com as
deidades, nós vamos usar o fato que a
pessoa tá presa numa bolha,
então ela já tem a mente focada.
Vocês entendem? Toda pessoa que tá presa
numa bolha, tu diz: "Não, não é que ela
esteja presa na bolha, ela tá com a
mente focada naquilo, ela não consegue
escapar daquilo."
Então, vamos supor, tem uma uma mãe que
tem um nível de sofrimento pelo
engajamento na vida familiar.
Nós precisamos de uma deidade que é uma,
os implementos da deidade é uma vassoura
e um esfregão
e uma pilha de fraldas ao redor, uma
coisa assim, né? A pessoa, ela, a mente
dela opera desse modo, né? Como é que
nós vamos atingir a liberação?
Nós invocamos essa deidade, ó, por
favor, deidade. Aí nós temos uma super
conexão. Eu não sei qual é o mantra
dessa deidade, né? Mas a gente tem uma
super conexão. A gente só precisa
revelar
pro para pobre praticante, no caso, não
é? que aquela deidade com todos aqueles
implementos, aquelas construções, é tudo
construído luminosamente. A pessoa não é
aquilo. Nós só precisamos primeiro
identificar com a deidade a pessoa. Sim,
eu sou essa deidade.
Ela é uma emanação do Buda primordial,
com certeza, porque todas as identidades
é tudo daqui, ó, reunião de todos os
samares num único ponto essencial. Então
nós estamos lá correndo, andando para
todo lado e nós somos essa deidade, né?
Aí vem o os que querem que a gente pare
com aquilo e faça chamata.
A gente vai dizer: "Eu não consigo
praticar chamada. Eu não tenho como, não
posso. Se eu parar, morre as crianças.
É assim, eu quer que eu pare? Como é
isso? Que gente insensível. Isso não é
possível.
Então tá tudo bem então. Então nós não
vamos fazer isso. Além do mais quando eu
sento em cháata, brota aquele turbilhão.
Eu só me lembro que não tirei a roupa do
na máquina para estender, que agora o
vio de sol já passou e que eu não tenho
mais as toalhas de banho estão tudo
molhado, eu esqueci de estender
assim. E amanhã as crianças vão paraa
escola e não vai ter roupa para eles. É
isso. E quer que eu medite? É isso.
Então a gente diz: "Não, não, não vai
ser isso. Você não vai se libertar pelo
zenho. Não é, não é assim.
Você entenda esse ser de múltiplos
braços que faz todas as coisas
acontecerem.
Esse ser é uma emanação do Buda
primordial. Nossa, pá, essa eu gostei.
Não, esse eu gostei. Claro, ninguém
entende isso, mas é, né? É assim. E qual
é a terra pura? A terra pura tem várias
salas, tem um banheiro, uma cozinha,
assim, tem um patiozinho, tem um
estendedor de roupa. São os implementos
da mandala,
mas tudo aquilo que tá ali é construído
pela mente, pessoal. Se eu não tiver
aquele engajamento, nada daquilo faz
sentido. Mas nós estamos imersos ali.
Então nós reconhecemos que aquilo tudo
brota com a manifestação luminosa. Eu tô
criando aquilo. Eu tô me criando como
identidade também naquilo.
E aí eu vejo o quê? Eu vejo a natureza
última produzindo esse ser cheios de
braços e pernas, que faz múltiplas
coisas e pensam em cinco, 10 coisas ao
mesmo tempo e vai salvando todo mundo,
que é um regente super eficaz. Então nós
precisamos, isso é uma emanação de tara,
área tara, não sei qual delas, eu acho
que é a salvadora.
A vela salvadoraim.
Então é isso aí. Aí nós sentimos
emanações da veloz salvadora.
Mas o se a gente reificar a veló
salvadora dissera, realmente tá em algum
lugar em cima de uma flor de lotos
cósmica, em cima do monte cailage,
melhor não, ela não tá lá, ela brota
diretamente da natureza livre que
constrói realidades imundos e seres.
Nós só precisamos reconhecer isso. A
gente não precisa cortar a dona de casa.
A gente ilumina a dona de casa. Vocês
entendem?
Aí os filhos adolescentes vão dizer:
"Minha mãe é iluminada".
Você se vire aí, mamãe, porque a
iluminação é sua.
Aí tem as emanações iradas de Tara.
[Música]
Assim, as emanações iradas são super
importantes. Por quê? Porque aí os
outros seres eles entram não só em
avidia como em moa. Ou seja, eles não,
eles estão amortecidos, eles estão na
normose.
Aí as mães não só tem que fazer aquilo
tudo como ainda tem que sacudir aqueles
seres, tem que derrubar aqueles seres
para eles acordarem.
Assim, eu acho que os homens ajudam, mas
é bem isso. As mulheres fazem, os homens
ajudam quando podem.
Eu acho que tem essa essa emanação. É
mais uma emanação feminina, se me parece
assim.
Eu tô me retirando.
Eu gosto dessa, desse papel.
fazer tudo acontecer. Mas eu não sei,
minha mãe ganha de 10 a 0
que eu possa fazer, porque ela era
alguma coisa.
Então,
virginiada,
qual agora Leuial nem pescou?
Perguntou ao mestre qual o ponto
essencial contém todos os locais de
permanência.
Locais de permanência seriam bolhas,
pessoal.
os locais onde nós estamos existindo.
O mestre respondeu:
"O darmadato imutável é o ponto
essencial, ou seja, a grande vacuidade
é o ponto essencial que contém todos os
locais de permanência. Todos os outros
locais, bolhas, perecem, elas surgem e
perece.
Vocês entendem isso mais ou menos?
Agora vejam como é que vocês conseguem
entender isso.
Como é que brota na mente a compreensão
de uma coisa dessas?
Não é do som das palavras.
Esse é a mente que vê a mente
funcionando.
Por exemplo, todas as bolhas construídas
surgem e cessam.
Mas quando elas cessam, elas cessam
aonde?
Elas cessam no espaço livre de bolhas.
E quando as novas bolhas surgem, elas
surgem da onde? No espaço livre, elas
surgem junto com as identidades que
estão operando. É um pouco assim, quando
o jogo de xadrez na partida termina,
para onde que ela vai?
A pergunta tem sentido, mas é isso.
Aquilo é uma bolha, ela
ela volta para lugar nenhum.
Então as nossas bolhas e esse nosso
encontro aqui, quando terminar amanhã ao
meio-dia, bateu no iceberg o Titanic,
o encontro foi para onde?
Terminou, não foi para lugar nenhum.
E o próximo encontro, ele brota da onde?
brota da natureza livre da mente.
E esse encontro ele brotou da onde? Da
natureza livre da mente. Não, ele não é
continuidade de nada,
ele brota.
Então tem uma natureza
livre, armadato imutável.
Quando tudo vai a zero, o zero ele é uma
existência, não uma ausência.
Esse é o dharmadato imutável.
Esse esse aspecto assim na matemática,
ele é muito importante, pessoal. Por
incrível que pareça, o zero levou um
tempo para existir,
para surgir.
O zero é uma
permanência.
Ainda que não tenha nada, ele é o número
mais importante de todos.
Dar uma data imotável ponto essencial de
todos os locais de permanência. Todos os
outros locais perecem.
Para os seres sencientes que falham em
realizar a natureza imutável de dar.
Seus locais de permanência, templos,
ciclos de vida,
circunstâncias,
ações e pensamentos, todos mudam,
enquanto o darmata permanece inalterado
por quaisquer circunstâncias ou emoções,
ao contrário dos locais de permanência
excelentes,
dos campos búdicos,
Então, os locais de permanência
excelentes dos campos búdicos, eles
também são criações.
Ou as terríveis moradas dos seres ssáos.
Nós vamos chamar terríveis moradas
porque os seres que estão ali dentro
sofrimento. Vocês pensem, as guerras
elas são
bolhas luminosas,
mas são campos horríveis.
É muito incrível, pessoal, porque as
pessoas se juntam, os mentores da
guerra, os sustentadores das bolhas se
cumprimentam, como aconteceu agora, né,
na Alasca, se cumprimentam e eles têm o
maior carinho um pelo outro,
mas isso não impede de que as pessoas
sigam morrendo.
Os criadores da guerra não se matam, mas
os outros que estão lá dentro ficam se
matando e morrendo e os outros não
querem guerrar.
Chega ser emocionante ver aqueles filmes
do dos ucranianos tentando escapar do
serviço militar nas outras agarrando
eles a força, jogando dentro de uma
caminhonete, soqueando eles para eles
virarem soldados. Eles sabem que vão
morrer. Eu eu assisti outro dia um
desses que foi pego, aí as mulheres
salvaram ele. Aí veio a esposa, começou
a bater naqueles outros lá e começou a
bater, veio uma outra amiga que começou
a bater e os grandão lá desistiram. E o
salvaram aquele aquele aquele ser que
quem sabe era o pai da família que
sustentava, que fazia as coisas andarem.
É assim, uma coisa desesperadora.
Mas aí tem uma bolha,
uma bolha que tu não sabe qual origem e
ela vai devorando as pessoas e vai
matando todo mundo.
É uma bolha. Como é que a gente sabe que
é uma bolha? Daqui a pouco vai fazer
assim, bim, e a guerra terminou.
Todo mundo que morreu disse: "Pá, morri
no dia errado." Morriu um dia antes.
O pessoal já tá assim. Eu não quero
morrer hoje, porque pode ser que amanhã
eu já não preciso mais morrer.
Hoje eu vou me esconder.
E aí, como é que é isso? Aí o pessoal
morreu no último dia, no último minuto.
Aí a guerra já tinha sido, já tinha
terminado, mas o pessoal não sabia.
ainda levou mais um tiro, aí morreu.
É isso, né? Como que uma bolha dessas se
sustenta e se mantém?
Então, essas são as terríveis moradas
dos seres sansáicos.
El, os seres humanos estão regidos por
condicionantes. Esses condicionantes
aquilo é construído e os seres humanos
eles estão no meio disso.
A natureza imutável de darmata não tá
sujeito a conceitos de bom ou mau. Ela
não pertence às bolhas, ela tá além
disso. Então, a gente já sabe, todas as
guerras terminam.
Natureza
livre da mente, ela é maior. Aí nós
vamos construir outras coisas.
Essa natureza que não é construída é
imutável.
Quando nós repousamos relaxadamente,
sem precisar fazer esforços, nós já
estamos dentro disso. Mais fácil de
reconhecer do que quando a gente tá
fazendo esforço.
Então, esse é o local de permanência
do darmadato. Darmadato é isso. A
realização dessa natureza é conhecido
como reunião de todos os locais de
permanência. Locais de permanência são
as bolhas em um único ponto essencial
que é a grande natural liberdade.
E agora Lady de Soguiel nem pescou.
E aí ela perguntou ao mestre
qual o ponto essencial contém todos os
caminhos.
Aí rebochê tem que tem que inventar
palavras, né? Tem que inventar coisas.
Ela fica só cutucando ele para ver se
aquilo sai.
[Risadas]
Eu diz: "Você tá assim obsessiva, chega
de perguntas."
Nem o mestre respondeu: "O caminho além
do caminho,
né? Todo caminho que é sair de um lugar
para chegar outro, não é?
é o caminho que já chegou, é o caminho
que não tem que não tem andamento.
Então, se nós acessamos aquilo que não
anda, esse é o caminho, é olhar tudo a
partir daquilo que não se move.
Mestre respondeu: "O caminho além da
jornada, ou seja, caminho além do
caminho, é o ponto essencial que contém
todos os caminhos.
Todos os outros caminhos mudam e não
perduram.
O caminho da mente desperta,
lúcido, que não se desloca. Mente
desperta e lúcida está além da jornada,
no sentido de que a mente desperta
essencialmente a sua verdadeira
natureza. O espaço básico, livro de
erro, a natureza não dual do do estado
de esperto lúcido, que já tá aí, você
não precisa sair correndo atrás.
Tem um no Sutra Surangama tem uma imagem
que eu acho muito interessante. Ela diz
que havia um louco em Stravast, né? Que
essa cidade Stravast, né? Mas viu um
louco e o louco se olhou no espelho e
viu que não tinha olhos.
Aí saiu correndo procurando seus olhos.
Como é que alguém pode se olhar no
espelho e se não tem olhos, né?
Então, mas é como a nossa situação, a
gente tá aqui olhando assim e vendo, mas
a gente pensa que não tem o olho
espiritual e aí nós saímos correndo
procurando. Mas esse aspecto profundo,
ele já tá presente, ele tá,
ele não se afasta, não tem como se
afastar, ele é a essência de toda a
manifestação.
Então nós eh o Buda não queria dizer,
mas ele já tava dizendo que nós somos o
louco de Stravast, que saímos correndo
procurando as coisas, sendo que as
coisas estão ali.
Então qual é o caminho? O caminho além
da jornada, além de ficar procurando, já
tá aqui.
Esse é o caminho que contei todos os
caminhos. Todos os outros caminhos mudam
e não perduram. O caminho da mente
desperta está além da jornada no sentido
de que a mente desperta essencialmente a
sua verdadeira natureza. O espaço
básico, livre de erros, a natureza não
dual do estado de esperto lúcido. Assim,
ao compreender como se engajar, como
reconhecer isso, como viver a partir
dessa consciência, isso é guru yoga, né?
Então, não há um caminho para atravessar
e nem uma jornada. No momento em que
você compreende essa natureza que
transcende o ir e ouvir, não há base
para um caminho concreto através do qual
você poderia ser transportado como por
um veículo.
E sendo não criado, ele é conhecido como
estado desperto indestrutível,
como um vágra.
A realização dessa natureza conhecida
com a reunião
de todos os caminhos em um único ponto
essencial.
de Tsugal nem pescou, nem ofereceu chá,
mas perguntou ao mestre, fale aí qual o
ponto essencial que contém todos os
caias? Então, Caias são os corpos, né?
corpo Darmacaia, Sambogaka Nirmanca,
Zobavecaia
e os caas deludidos.
O mestre respondeu:
"O dharmaia imutável
é o ponto essencial de todos os caias.
É o corpo imutável, que é o corpo, é a
vacuidade.
Todos os outros caias mudam e não
perduram. Então todos os corpos que a
gente gerar, eles
não perduram, eles mudam.
Darmacaia permanece imaculado pelas
limitações
da substância e atributos. Ou seja, ele
não tem substância e não tem atributos.
Ele não muda, pois essa forma não
manifesta, é indestrutível em todas as
circunstâncias.
Os caias rotulados pelo pensamento, tais
como sambogakaias e nermanacaias,
todos mudam.
Tá certo que eles mudam, mas vamos
defender o sambogakaia, né? Sambogakai é
como se fosse esse texto aqui.
Eles, os textos mudam, mas eles são
expressões de darmaka.
São emanação de darmaka. E são e os
nermanaca são os corpos dos budas e
bodissáas. Eles mudam, mas eles também
são expressões para poder operar dentro
dos mundos condicionados dos seres, né?
A palavra cai é definida como
indestrutível, pois permanece inalterada
sobre qualquer circunstância.
A compreensão e a realização dessa
natureza são conhecidas como a reunião
de todos os caias em um único ponto
essencial que é a dharmaia.
Aíal perguntou ao mestre, então é como
se ela tivesse pegando a variedade de
aparências e fazendo sempre convergir
pro ponto. Ela sabe que aquilo converge.
Então ela vai pedindo para guru pochê
para ele falar isso.
Ele perguntou ao mestre, ela perguntou
ao mestre para proveito dos seres tontos
dos templos vindos. Me diga qual o ponto
essencial contém todas as vozes? Nós
estamos ouvindo vozes. Não sei se vocês
já ouviram vozes. Pois é, a gente tá
sempre em diálogo interno, né?
O mestre respondeu:
"A voz da natureza insubstancial".
Pronto, claro, é a voz que clarifica as
coisas.
A voz da natureza insubstancial é o
ponto essencial que contém todas as
vozes. As outras vozes mudam e não
perduram.
As vozes dos seres sencientes aparecem
como som e então cessam.
Ao realizar a natureza insubstancial de
dar mata, você compreende que as vozes
de todos os seres são desprovidas de
substância. concreta também.
Os sons são a vacuidade audível, vazia
de identidade.
Eu acho interessante isso.
Por exemplo, vocês vejam, a vacuidade,
ela é é um aspecto que é reconhecido
pela não dualidade e, portanto, também
com uma manifestação,
[Música]
clarificação das bolhas, né?
Então, quando aqui, por exemplo, eu tô
produzindo sons, né, que é muito
parecido com escrever um texto num
papel. Aí quando a gente olha o texto no
papel, não é os riscos, a gente não vê
os riscos, nós vê uma outra coisa aqui
também, não é o, não é o som que vocês
estão ouvindo, vocês estão ouvindo
significados.
Fica muito visível isso, porque se fosse
uma pessoa de uma outra língua falando
aqui, a gente não ia entender nada. Ele
podia est dizendo a mesma coisa, mas a
gente não vai entender nada. Por quê?
Porque nós não temos um decodificador
cármico que produz significados. Aí eu
não vejo, não entendo nada.
Então, não são os sons
e do mesmo modo não são as luzes,
é uma operação da mente.
Então,
as outras vozes mudam e não perduram. As
vozes dos seres sencientes aparecem como
som e então cessam. Ao realizar a
natureza insubstancial doarmata, você
compreende que as vozes de todos os
seres são desprovidas de substância
concreta. Também os sons são a vacuidade
audível, vazia de identidade. Eles
ocorrem desimpedidos
a partir da natureza vazia, porque essa
natureza autoexistente,
ela não tem substância, ela não tem
referencial insubstancial.
A compreensão e a realização dessa
natureza
são conhecidas como a reunião de todas
as vozes em um único ponto essencial,
que é o quê? A voz da natureza
insubstancial.
Nossa voz, ela tá ligada à compreensão,
né? Clareza.
A minha leide deal não desiste. Aí ela
perguntou: "Mestre, qual o ponto
essencial que contém todos os estados
mentais?"
Nós já estamos vendo. Pode perguntar
para mim que eu sei. Então já
respondu.
A igualdade livro de confusões
é o ponto é o ponto essencial que contei
todos os estados mentais.
Os outros estados mentais mudam e não
perduram. A mente dos budas está livre
da delusão e não é elaborada.
Ela é uma igualdade ilimitada,
na qual as falhas da confusão foram
eliminadas e o estado desperto da
sabedoria
desabrochou.
Então esse é o ponto essencial que
contém todos os estados mentais.
O estado mental de um ser senciente
falha em compreender a si mesmo. Então
esse é um estado mental de um ser
sensiente. Por que que ele falha a
compreender a si mesmo? Vocês imaginem,
vocês estão jogando um jogo de
tabuleiro,
aí vocês vão mover um peão, vocês
pensam: "Uau, que profundo! Esse peão é
não existente, mas ele vai ele vai mudar
de posição e vai produzir um resultado,
sendo que isso aqui é tudo vazio,
iluminoso. Que incrível isso.
E a pessoa atinge iluminação, não vai
até o fim do jogo. Aí não dá, não é um
jogador direito, entendeu?
Então esses são seres sencientes. Seres
sensientes operam dentro daquilo, né? N
se vocês, um de vocês de repente dá um
grito, estou iluminado, saí andando, aí
já estragou tudo, porque nós estamos
aqui, a pessoa tem que ser séria, não
pode atingir iluminação. Eu ten que
seguir até o fim o retiro. Vocês
entendem? É isso.
Então, esse é um ser senciente. Seres
senciantes não podem gritar e dizer
assim, não. Eles são sérios. Eles
cumprem o que precisam cumprir. Então, o
estado mental de um ser senciente fala
em compreender a si mesmo. Se ele
compreende a si mesmo, ele se livra de
si mesmo. E os fenômenos superficiais
ilusórios do envolvimento com os
veículos gerais
e as bolhas são todos delusão. E eles
são o agente da delusão.
mente desperta, livro de erros, não
elaborada, livro das limitações do
esforço,
contém cada estado mental dos budas.
A compreensão e a realização dessa
natureza são conhecidas como a reunião
de todos os estados mentais em um único
ponto essencial.
Esses textos todos foram traduzidos por
esse mestre, né? Esse mestre dinamarquês
que é o Eric.
Então ele tá vindo ao Brasil agora. Acho
que é a primeira vez que ele vem ao
Brasil. Não sei se ele veio antes. Aí
ele tá indo a viamão agora em outubro.
Então, Leid de Soguiel perguntou ao
mestre: "Qual o ponto essencial que
contém todos os samaias?"
Então, samaia são os votos de manter a
clareza da mente.
O mestre respondeu: "A expansão total,
a grande expansão é o ponto essencial
que contém todos os samaias, visto que
ela está além de sustentação
de uma forma temporal. Então, a quebra
de samaia, né, quando a gente perde a
lucidez, é quando a gente sustenta uma
forma temporal ou temporária, que seria
isso, né? Então, vamos supor, nós
estamos aqui no retiro, sustentando o
retiro até amanhã ao meio-dia. Isso é
quebra de Samel.
Quem seguir no retiro,
porque a gente se constrói como alguém
aqui dentro. Aí vocês vergonhosamente
não saem no meio do da fala do lama,
vocês não vão no banheiro, não tomam
chá, levam a sério, retira, tá todo
mundo perdido.
Aí nós viramos identidade dentro desse
retiro. É assim, mas tá certo. Eu acho
melhor assim, né?
A gente segue assim, mas a gente ilumina
isso. Então, a gente ilumina essas
identidades. A gente, uau,
eu tô aqui operando sem nem perceber
como uma identidade dentro de um retiro
que também é construído luminosamente.
Isso é simplesmente inacreditável. Eu
aqui dentro da levanto o braço e baixo o
braço. Dentro dessa bolha levanto outro
braço e baixo o braço. Aí eu me eu dou
uma espreguiçada. Aí eu mexo no meu
cabelo assim dentro dessa bolha.
Isso não é que não é apenas mexer no
cabelo ou mexer o braço para cá ou para
lá ou se arrumar. É fazer tudo isso
dentro da bolha, sem perder a bolha,
entende? É incrível.
É assim. Aí nós iluminamos isso, nós
iluminamos esse aspecto todo. Ele é
delusivo, mas já não é delusivo, ele é
apresentação de como as realidades
aparecem e como que a gente se engaja e
se move dentro delasim.
Aí nós já estamos voltando lá pro
Satipatana Sutra. Satipatana. Isso. Nós
estamos lá meditando, contemplando o
corpo. Fala mente, contemplando o corpo.
Aí
levanta e baixa o braço, pá. Que
incrível. Aí de novo, ele levanta o
braço, baixa o braço, pá. Incrível. Aí
já vem um pessoal forte lá e recolhe
ele.
Mais um que enlouqueceu.
Ele se inclinou pra frente, se inclinam
para trás. Uau! funciona. Vai para cá,
vai para lá
e tudo isso dentro da bolha e todo mundo
tá achando normal.
Então é isso aí. A pessoa se constrói
daquele modo, né?
É como alguém na festa de formatura, né?
Todas as roupas, chapéu.
Eu sou um trouxa completo
que tem que fazer uma cara inteligente
paraas fotos.
Sim. Bonito isso
aí. A expansão total é o lugar livre
onde as bolhas surgem, as identidades e
os movimentos dentro das bolhas.
A mente desperta é livre de falhas e
obscurecimentos, portanto, ela é pura. e
clara.
Ela é o nosso referencial. Se a gente
tiver ali, nós não perdemos o Samaia.
Estando livre de objetos virtuosos a
serem aceitos, objetos enganosos a serem
rejeitados. A mente desperta não
consiste nem em algo a ser sustentado,
nem o ato de sustentar. Então não tem
esforço nisso.
Mas nós estamos vendo o aspecto lúdico,
o aspecto luminoso daquilo, entende?
A pessoa não precisa ficar sempre
lembrando, mas ela tá vendo,
ela tem a fruição dessa visão
extraordinária
desse aspecto delusivo,
visto que não há oscilações em tal
natureza. O não afastamento deste estado
realizado é conhecido como a expansão
total que transcende a sustentação de um
samaia.
Às vezes os praticantes têm uma um pouco
de aflição
eh com uma sensação de que eles não
estão sendo bons praticantes, né? do
tipo, uau, eu vejo, todo mundo entra no
templo e faz prostrações e faz tudo
certo e conhece como é que faz, não
passa com pé por cima do dos livros, né?
Como aqui ninguém passa com pé por cima
dos livros
e não senta com os pé pra frente também,
que aqui também ninguém senta com pé
para frente. Aí nós olhamos, todo mundo
faz tudo certinho, tudo direito, né?
Quando Lama chega, todo mundo se
levanta, depois se senta. Aí eu também
tô fazendo isso, mas eu tô achando isso
uma palhaçada.
Eu tô achando isso muito estranho. Sei,
né? Quem é que é melhor, os que fazem
aquilo ou os que acham estranho?
Os que acham estranho a melhor pessoa.
Então, por exemplo, quando nós nos
fixamos no aspecto externo, aí nós
estamos com problemas assim. Nós estamos
quebrando samaia, por incrível que
pareça, porque nós estamos fixando
realidades como se fossem verdadeiras
assim.
Mas se a gente tá dentro daquilo e diz:
"Uau, que incrível, tudo isso criado,
isso aqui é uma terra pura". É natural
que aqui a gente tenha outros
pensamentos e outras formas de andar.
Tudo isso aqui é construído aí é
interessante,
mas se a gente reifica, a gente coloca
um uma coisa muito densa ali, por
incrível que pareça, nós provavelmente
vamos renascer nos infernos.
Quebra de samia é fatal, porque o que
acontece? Eu reifico por um tempo,
depois eu hostilizo.
Vocês entenderem?
Porque dentro do sansara nós subimos e
descemos. Aí quando a gente hostiliza,
nós vamos pro nós afundamos os mundos de
sofrimento.
E a gente considera que as coisas
sagradas não são sagradas, elas não têm
sentido. Aquilo tudo é um engano, né? Eu
já vi pessoas no
se aproximarem e dizerem: "Eu não
deveria estar aqui dentro.
Todo mundo vê que eu não tô, eu não sou
daqui. Então eu acho isso correto.
Pessoa não é dali,
significa que ela aquilo não faz muito
sentido para ela.
Então isso é um ponto de lucidez,
porque se a gente se ajusta às coisas,
nós estamos também criando uma outra
bolha e surgindo com outras identidades.
Aquilo já deu problema. Nós precisamos
iluminar isso, ver o aspecto
extraordinário
disso tudo, né?
Contáveis milhões
não, como é que é? Visto que não
oscilações nessa natureza ampla, não nos
afastamos desse estado realizado. Isso é
que é manter samaia. Isso é conhecido
como expansão total que transcende a
sustentação de um samaia. Samia é com
voto, uma um comportamento, né? Isso
transcende.
Então a lucidez transcende o Samaia.
Incontáveis milhões de samaios genéricos
podem ser quebrados.
Portanto, a gente não deveria ter
raivas, nem rancores, nem atacar os
outros verbalmente, nem uma série de
coisas. E são samaias
genéricos. Então, incontáveis milhões de
samaias genéricos podem ser quebrados e,
portanto,
o obrigam fortemente a sustentá-los.
Mas a compreensão, a realização dessa
natureza
ampla
são conhecidas como a reunião de todos
os samaias em um único ponto essencial.
Então, se a gente continuar mantendo
essa compreensão da natureza livre, de
onde as coisas surgem, aí nós
nós mantemos todos os tamanhos.
Então, nós vamos parar nesse ponto aqui.
Então, nós estaremos no 12º.
Nós vamos retornar no 12º.
O Lady Togal perguntou ao mestre qual o
ponto essencial que contém todas as
virtudes?
Qual é o ponto? Nós já estamos
é o ponto último sempre que ele vai
ganhando ele, a gente pode olhar com
diferentes modos aqui, ele vai ganhando
diferentes nomes, mas é sempre o mesmo
ponto.
Isso corresponde à visão da terceira
volta do dharma.
Terceira volta do dharma faz tudo
convergo.
É assim, a grande vacuidade,
luminosidade, de onde tudo brota.
A segunda volta do dharma, eh, é uma
visão
que
que na verdade só tem uma volta do
dharma, que é assim, ou o dharma lúcido
ou não é lúcido.
É assim, né?
Mas é como se o dharma lúcido ele
tivesse sido apresentado várias vezes e
se desgastou. Aí ele fica com tem uma
narrativa, tem grupos que mantém uma
visão que é um pouco insuficiente.
Então, por isso que a gente vai
descrever a primeira volta, a segunda
volta, que é como aquela aquela
apresentação completa ficou desgastada.
Aí de novo, então a segunda volta do
dharma, ela tá presa na vacuidade
malmurada,
que eu chamo de malmurada. Ou seja, eu
digo, não, aquilo não é assim. Por
exemplo, nós estamos num evento, esse
evento é uma criação, ele não não é
nada.
Aí nós perdemos o aspecto lúdico de ver
a natureza luminosa produzindo. Eu perco
essa capacidade de ver esse aspecto
último. Eu fico preso nas aparências.
E a primeira volta do dharma, ela surgiu
quando todos os ensinamentos foram
dados, mas as pessoas no fim elas
guardaram apenas aquilo, não matar, não
roubar, não isso, não aquilo, manter uma
moralidade de base,
assim, e sustentar estados mentais
específicos,
Mas o ponto que o Boda, vocês vão olhar
os nicas, por exemplo, que são os
ensinamentos originais do Boda, que
estão em Pale, né? Eles são lembrados,
eles são sustentados pelas tradições que
hoje são apontados com primeira volta do
dharma, mas eles não olham com esse olho
assim. Eles olham, eles têm aqueles
textos lá, mas eles ficam, eles fazem
uma prática muito mais simples.
Mas dentro dos nicas, o Buda explica a
iluminação dele de vários modos
e a iluminação dele sempre converge para
esse ponto dessa lucidez, que aqui é
como o estado de esperto doido, né?
Então aqui nós estamos vendo essa é uma
é uma a classe desse ensinamento
pertence terceira volta do Darva
e aos ensinamentos que são chamados de
instrução piedosa.
Porque se vocês olharem com cuidado, não
tem caminho aqui.
Essas instruções não tem caminho. Não
diz faça isso, faça aquilo ele só diz
assim, tem esse ponto. Veja esse ponto,
veja aquele ponto. Então, o ponto é
visão. Como que a gente vê
direto, sem precisar fazer nada antes.
Mas esses ensinamentos são super
especiais.
Hoje à noite, depois do Puja, eu vou dar
um ensinamento pra Velha Senhora. Vou
trazer esse ensinamento de guru por a
velha senhora, porque a velha senhora
representa
um sentimento de inferioridade que a
gente possa ter, porque a gente não
consegue olhar. Então, vem a velha
senhora e diz: "Ah, mas eu não tenho
inteligência, eu não tenho memória, eu
não tenho capacidade de compreensão,
eu eu tô no fim da vida, né? me deêu um
ensinamento que eu resolvo assim porque
eu preciso disso. Então, guru pocheira
assediada aí e aal e aí essa velha
senhora também aí, né?
E ele vai lá e pum e dá um ensinamento
super bonito, assim, ensinamento curto.
Então, como a gente já olhou essas
várias coisas, a gente consegue entender
esse ensinamento. Então, hoje nós vamos
olhar isso porque a gente precisa
ultrapassar essa sensação de que a gente
não consegue.
Aí isso é poderoso.
Então,
nós vamos fazer a dedicação agora. Que
os méritos desse encontro se expandam e
toquem a todos. Que o Mestre Universal
da Paz e da Compaixão, Sua Santidade da
Leilama, juntamente com todos os mestres
e todas as tradições que veiculam essa
mensagem, tenham longa vida. Que todos
estejam a salvo de gerar pensamentos
negativos, o obstáculo mais destrutivo,
que esses pensamentos nunca surgem em
nossa mente.
estejam livres de pensamentos negativos
ao longo de minhas muitas vidas e até
este momento, todas as virtudes que t
alcançado, inclusive os méritos gerados
por esta prática e todas as que vier a
conseguir ofereço para o bem-estar dos
seres sencientes.
possam uma doença, guerra, fome e
sofrimento diminuir para todos os seres,
enquanto sua sabedoria e compaixão
aumentam nesta em vidas futuras. Possa
eu claramente perceber todas as
experiências como sendo tão
insubstanciais quanto o tecido do sonho
durante a noite e imediatamente
despertar para perceber a natureza.
[Música]
Liberação de todos os seres, bodas e
bodissátuas em conjunto. Seja qual for a
sua motivação, sua ação benéfica e
preces auspiciosas,
seja qual for a sua iniciência,
realizações e poderes benévolos. E seja
qual for a sua imensa sabedoria,
eu queente venho para beneficiar os
seres, rogo para que possa alcançar as
mesmas qualidades.
Este exato momento possam nem mesmo os
nomes doença, fome, guerra e sofrimento
ser ouvidos pelas pessoas e nações da
terra, mas possam sim sua conduta moral,
mérito, riqueza e prosperidade
cresceram.
e possam a suprema bem-aventurança e
bem-estar sempre surgir para ela.
[Música]
[Risadas]
Beijo aí, pessoal.
Beijo aí. Beijo, só o Bruno, Sônia,
Helen.
>> Beijo, Lama.
Beijo Lama.
>> Obrigada.
>> Já depois.
>> Só depois.
>> Depois.
>> É depois.